these are no ordinary caterpillars these
are the bugs of the future bread and
mass to make Brazilian farming more
efficient and more profitable Brazil has
always been a breadbasket to the world
it's the biggest exporter of coffee
sugar beef chicken and orange juice and
therefore also the world's biggest
consumer of chemical pesticides decades
of overuse led to millions of resistant
thugs leaving Brazil looking for new
solutions one firm on the cutting edge
is now fighting fire with fire
it's called buck and they're creating
wealth superbugs genetically engineered
to work as an alternative to chemical
pesticides well controllable large
growers um a biological agents are much
cheaper than using traditional
pesticides and on top of that it doesn't
harm the environment and it doesn't harm
the crops these microscopic wasps are
what made bug a pioneer in biological
agents they're actually killer wasps
when released in a field they stop
harmful parasites from reproducing
protecting soybean and sugar cane fields
two of Brazil's biggest cash crops so
what's the technology behind these
high-tech bugs the secret is in the
sauce literally bugs team engineered an
artificial diet to grow these insects
it's the key to their biological design
and their profits which is why this is
one secret they aren't sharing bug was
founded by three Brazilian entrepreneurs
and backed by a Brazilian venture
capital team I think the few things
really called our eyes and I looked at
but first of all the entrepreneurs
really had a spark in their eyes not the
spark to make money but the spark to
make a difference they wanted to change
the way modern agriculture is done in
one of the largest agricultural markets
such as Brazil but is looking to disrupt
not only agriculture but also the seven
billion dollar pesticide market here in
Brazil the company has just 3% of the
biological agent market
but these entrepreneurs expect to be a
dominant player soon as the buzz about
bug catches on